Hello Freak bitches is a lot of guys.
I'm super talented.
They just love to eat,
you know,
man,
it's crazy.
Like a lot of those folks will,
we'll go to food for comfort for that and for the control control.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Especially in such a crazy world.
The world of competition in combat sports,
especially in this sport where like winning lossing is so finite and when you
get to the top like nobody,
well,
rarely people win more than they lose.
Right?
Like it's just so hard,
so hard.
And there's so many with the,
you know,
like in,
in NFL and major league baseball and soccer,
there's a clear pecking order.
You beat this person that you beat this team,
then you'd beat this team.
Then you get to play for the championship or an MMA.
It's not like that.
Well,
it's definitely not anymore.
You know,
in the UFC it's real weird.
Like,
especially the 185 pound division,
like good fucking luck.
Oh,
you know,
everybody's waiting in line to fight Michael Bisping.
He's probably going to fight George St Pierre.
People like Luke Rockhold.
So those other guys,
like what the fuck when he beat Rockhold,
that's my single favorite MMA moment history.
Really.
I'm not like obnoxious Bisbing fan or anything,
but that was the culmination of a dude who put in so much time and he did
everything to make it a business.
He did everything he and then he not only steps in and fights,
I just killer and Rockhold who I thought it has been underrated his whole
career.
Like he's this insanely good,
but he'd already got,
he'd already lost to them convincingly.
Like you know,
back then subbed in the first round.
Yeah.
And older guys don't come back and beat younger guys in the rematch ever.
Right.
Especially on short notice.
Short notice when he had a whole camp and has every reason to not have
confidence in like 90% or more,
fighters would have just been like,
no,
I'm out.
Like no way.
He takes the flight,
like no one would take that flight because if you lose twice to the champion,
you're,
you're done.
Right.
He ain't gonna get third.
Just every risk possible.
And he just nails it like this.
Unbelieve clips him and knocks him out.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Like I loved the rock whole book.
That was just incredible.
It really was crazy.
And you could really tell that Rockhold just thought he was gonna win the fight
no matter what.
Right.
This is a done deal.
Totally underestimated him.
Piss pink.
So scrappy that he's one of the most mentally tough guys in the sport because he
doesn't have like some freakish you,
our Merrill athleticism or anything.
He's just,
it's just hard work.
He's not particularly fast.
No,
he's not.
He's not super mobile.
He's,
he's very skilled and he's got a lot of physical issues too.
Came see at a one I,
yeah.
You know,
he's had a bunch of issues with like joints and disks and he doesn't move well.
He's,
no,
and he's not a big for the division or anything.
Just people that,
well,
he's pretty big for one 85 well,
not like amazing.
What?
He's not like towering over men are Rockhold like,
no,
he's not beat.
Those guys are giants.
Yeah.
Those guys are giant.
He doesn't have some amazing skill set.
Either way,
he can fall back on a world championship in wrestling to get through.
Like he just is like pretty good at everything.
Yup.
Yeah.
Was still just finds a way off yet.
He's a guy I would love to biopsy and figured out like how much slow twitch and
fast twitch does he have 34 beats per minute resting heart rate.
He's fit.
Yeah it's a big factor.
It's a big factor.
And then he could push a tremendous pace and then keep it going.
Like one of my favorite fights of a Michaels was a,
when he beat Kung Lee.
Oh yeah.
Cause he's overwhelmed them and just you see cotton starting to get tired and
Bisping just poured it on.
Yeah.
Just gave him a beating.
And that was sort of a,
in a lot of ways like a,
a shift towards,
I mean he was always a world class fighter.
There was a shift towards the upper end of the,
of the division.
And it's a big moment for his career too.
Cause if he lost that,
that's probably about night night for him in terms of he could say that,
but he doesn't give a fuck you,
he got knocked out by Vitara,
comes right back.
You know,
he got knocked out by Henderson,
comes right back.
He's one of the guys.
I've been around him a bit.
Uh,
he,
he's Hilarious,
but he's,
one of the guys were again,
like he doesn't,
he just not going to shake him like that.
No,
not at all.
He's undeniably tough.
Yeah.
And he's undeniably like when he says like all fight that dude.
He,
he legit.
Oh yeah,
he's there.
Yeah.
And you can say like,
oh,
he's scared of Romero.
No,
he's not like,
he's not scared of any of these students he's trying to cash in when he's like,
well,
I think the Bisping GSP fight is a fascinating fight.
It's fascinating.
First of all,
GSPS never fought at 85 he comes back,
he fights for a world title.
It makes it compelling.
Yeah.
I just wonder if this is unfortunate,
but I wonder how many of these young new fans,
I would like to say like post Ronda Rousey fans,
how many of them,
you know who fucked GSP is?
I think there's a lot in,
my wife definitely does well.
She's a fan.
Yeah.
But I mean I'm wonder of how many of the new ones,
you know,
the people coming up actually know who he is and I mean it's been a long time.
Yeah.
You know,
a couple of years,
right?
More than that.
When did he lose to Johnny Hendricks?
I want to say it's three years ago at least.
At least.
Yeah.
Well Pete,
Tony Hendrix.
Yeah,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not a big believer in that decision.
I feel like at most that was the draw.
I felt like Hendrix got the most event.
My buddy Troy brother had 50 k on Hendrix on that fight.
Did he?
Yeah.
And afterwards he's like,
here we go.
Like for done.
Hendrickson was interesting because a Hendrick's is one of those guys that you
go like,
what happened to that guy?
You know?
Like what a lot of speculation on that where you can all read between the lines
there.
Well that's,
that's the problem,
right?
Yeah.
There's the Usada speculation.
There's the motivation,
speculation.
There's a lot of speculation.
You also have that thing to what guys like that that put it in that many years
of wrestling and he started competing that hard,
that young [inaudible] like that that wears on you.
It was a timeframe out of,
yeah,
there's a,
like p people believe there's a nine year window as a world class fighter.
Have heard that before.
It depends on the sport,
but yeah,
that's probably fair as a fighter,
as a fighter,
like can you get to MMA in particular guys have like nine years to compete at a
world class level and then the wheels just fall off.
Yeah.
Get in and get your money and get out.
If you can,
if you can.
Yeah.
That's why 38 I think bespeaks 38 dead GSP fights the right move.
Oh,
for a hundred so right move.
Anyway.
Yeah.
What does a Bisbing typically do well with like the fighters?
Like he handles rustlers decently well.
He's a very good defensive wrestler.
His styles can be fantastic.
Yeah.
It doesn't get tired,
which is what DSB relied on a lot is,
is his stamina.
Conditioning was great.
But yeah,
that stamina like is dependent upon activity.
Like do you,
even if you're just physically fit,
but you haven't fought in a long time,
but I don't necessarily know if it's,
it's applicable.
Yeah.
Well it's also going to be different too with we'll see what he does weight
wise.
Yeah.
So what people don't understand about when you watch professional athletes
fighters in particular is a lot of what happens in that fatigue is either
psychological or it's bad weight cut stuff.
So now he doesn't have that.
But if he's lugging around extra weight,
um,
that he's not used to potentially problematic depending on how he does it.
Now he's got some smart people in this camp,
so he's probably going to be fine.
Yeah.
But that's a real problem.
Um,
that,
that he may or may not be ready for.
Yeah.
If he's lugging around extra way.
But he was always walking around.
It's somewhere around one 85 one 90 he might just decide to compete at that
weight.
That's what I mean.
Like if he stays there,
he's probably fine,
but if someone gets in his head and tries to get them up to two oh two or
something and then come back down,
like he's probably not going to feel normal there.
Yeah.
When she's not going to run out of gas.
Because of that,
like having more muscle doesn't make you fatigue more.
It's the training that does it.
Okay.